retour progressif des gones sur les
bancs des écoles lyonnaises dans la
capitale des gaules
les élèves reprennent petit à petit le
chemin des courts du moins une partie
d'entre eux ce 14 mai seuls les écoliers
de grande section de maternelle de cp et
de cm2 font leur rentrée
l'activité scolaire reprend donc
timidement ce jeudi comme à l'école
élémentaire chapeau rouge situé dans le
quartier de vaise dans le 9e
arrondissement
en temps normal l'établissement
accueille 120 élèves ils le sont
aujourd'hui pas plus de six ou sept par
classe nous accueillir une partie de nos
élèves mais ça se passe calmement
est-ce que les gens étaient préparés on
a eu le temps de leur expliquer un petit
peu comment on allait procéder
donc ça se passe calmement et
sereinement nous avons pour le moment un
tiers de nos grands qu'on est en
maternelle grande section
mais ça devrait augmenter les parents
sens
certains sont en attente de voir comment
va se passer ces premiers jours pour
pouvoir remettre leurs enfants on a été
en continu en continuité en contact avec
eux depuis l'arrêt de l'école donc ce
qui fait que non il n'y a pas de
question à ce moment précis puisqu'on a
la plus discutée pendant toute la
période avec eux
si les enfants ne porte pas de masque
ces derniers sont en revanche
obligatoire pour les adultes les parents
sont par ailleurs accueilli à
l'extérieur de l'établissement par le
personnel et sont priés de respecter une
distance de 3 m
des mesures sanitaires qui rassure ceux
qui ont volontairement remis leurs
enfants à l'école ce qui nous a décidés
c'est qu'il ya deux poids et d'avoir ma
fille avait très envie de reprendre
l'école
donc elle l'est elle le réclamait donc
du coup on s'est dit bon il ce cas là il
faut l'emmener
et puis aussi on est confiant par
rapport aux par rapport à tout ce qui
est mis en place voilà donc on s'est dit
faisons nous on est plutôt partisan du
fait que certes il faut faire attention
mais il faut aussi revivre on va pas
rester enfermé toute notre vie donc que
bien un moment où il faut mettre le pied
à l'étrier et reprendre la vie on est
très confiants par rapport au dispositif
voilà toutes les mesures sont prises on
est très confiants sur cette reprise
voilà moi je suis content qu'il revienne
à l'école pour lui pour revoir les
copains la maîtresse voilà on verra
comment ça se passe le calendrier fixé
par la ville de lyon prévoit un retour
des classes de cm1 le 25 mai les élèves
de ce1 et de ce2 devront te attendre le
4 juin pour retrouver leurs camarades
quant au nombre d'enfants par classe il
a été fixé à 15 élèves maximum